[Music]  hi I'm ready Maya google developer  advocate and I'm still here with Dave  Renton director of customer reliability  engineering so Dave I've always thought  the vests Ariz is the first responders  in the computing world and everything is  catching fire and falling down you guys  are running in has there ever been a  situation where you wanted to turn  around and run the other way you like or  when a hurricane with threatening the  wipe most of the eastern seaboard off  not yes exactly like that well what does  preparation for something like that look  like a inflatable life raft a life  jacket it's a little more involved than  that but if you want to hear the whole  story and more join us at Google next at  the 59 lounge dedicated space for sre  and DevOps people where you'll hear all  the wonderful wild wacky sometimes just  plain weird stories of what it's like to  run a production system at web-scale  look forward to seeing either